- ago and break my spirit if I welcome
to the absolute final episode of beyond
to sauce let's do it alright let's see
yeah let's see what ending we get
ever since the Black Sun was destroyed
my memory has been disintegrating we
spent too much time on the other side
now it's eating away at my mind really
erasing what's left of it my memories
are all confused
slowly self-destructing fading like a
dream when you wake up I'm losing my
sense of time that's not good I no
longer know what happened before or
after what
everything's playing inside my head at
the same time no it's like watching the
same film looping over Y over again what
why the [ __ ] did we get this end in
chaos of images with no order so I've
been writing night and day for weeks
trying to put my life down on paper
if I forget everything these pages will
be my memory what months after the fact
the investigation continues in an effort
to determine the cause of the accident
that cost 283 lives on a Pentagon
military base government representatives
confirm that the authorities are working
hand-in-hand with the investigators to
shed light on this appalling tragedy the
CIA is leaving me alone for the moment I
suppose they're too busy building
another condenser to worry about
I know they'll never abandon their
experiments my lightnings gone any mouth
they know it's on the other side
honestly I don't give a damn now I need
to reconstruct my life it's about time
my life without ID for as long as I can
remember I dreamt of living without him
untied without his constant presence by
myself
I got what I wanted
I've never been so unhappy in my life
we just [ __ ] got the bad ending
anyway part of me has been amputated
crying all day
I know it's stupid [ __ ]
I miss him so much no [ __ ] ways at
the ending thank you get tools get to
see what happened to : Ryan and I I
guess that's it honestly what the hell I
picked to go back because I actually
sent in the letter no return your
address
took months that's of nothing passing by
and I woke up it was time time to start
again build a new life oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] no don't you dare fade away or
some [ __ ] like that don't pressure me
right now don't pressure me game I'm
gonna go we're gonna go through this
okay
so she just lost what am i eating she's
not gonna be alone for the rest her life
that's [ __ ] I did not make her go
back so she would die alone no if I
wanted her to be alone I would let a kid
okay Zoey no why the [ __ ] is that even
an option are you serious no okay so
here's the old Matt Jay alright holy
[ __ ] this is a really [ __ ] tough
position yeah I never thought cheersing
between two men would be a hard one not
that it would be an easy one it's that I
feel like okay here's what I feel like I
feel like Jay is cool and all and I
really like Jay and I think Jay is
probably best for her but then again we
don't know [ __ ] about him all we know
that he lives in the desert and it's
kind of sorta nice once he get to know
him Ryan he they have a past together
they grew up together
and even though they hated each other
our not hate each other but they had
their differences I feel like in the end
Ryan changed you know he punched a
military guy and be like [ __ ] you I
I rested the resigner or whatever I feel
like he changed and he won he's nice now
so that's why my gold my chose is Ryan
I chose right even though I [ __ ] hate
him
hashtag inside [ __ ] Ryan always knew I
just needed the silence around me or me
clicking the Xbox hear what I was
feeling
no I did it I did it Jody you didn't do
it you're welcome
I you hear what I'm saying here don't
tell me I make the wrong I've been alone
sad for so long I forgotten what it was
like doing
he has an iPad now it's Kaizen instead
of being a [ __ ] he's kind of a badass
you know I'm just saying it looks like
it wears lip gloss so it kind of
balances it out you know lip gloss
eyepatch gay as best not that there's
anything wrong with that
and thus concludes the office farley I
had the one to love again I thought you
already said you loved put my trust in
someone to stop fighting and running
away
sure
I had to learn to live of course they go
in a boat that [ __ ] I just about it
again a deaf figure very nice
as if the other side didn't exist as if
it could never come back into our lives
until you die oh I get it
oh sure
let's fight for Ryan
what is that is that I didn't
he couldn't just write something in the
sand
oh there we go
I mean I'm so probably she hasn't got
all sunburned
so white damn
there we go there we go
I don't know what Ryan saw that fire why
isn't he just going over hmm
well anyhow Oh God
why am I always wrong these things at
night
terrifying thing that's it that's the
thing we saw before I'm the future tell
myself it's only nightmares but I know I
know don't him get sleep well true once
Pandora's Box is open
can never be closed
that's what is about that
I've died twice already I'm not afraid
of dozen you what
next time
I was so afraid that most
how much time do we have it back to me
the self destroy I come back
is
she's magnums
oh wait that soundtrack makan simmer
collaboration
all right
time for some final thoughts Hey
convinced Dawkins I guess that was a
thing you can do that's cool what else
did we do
we chills life that we dead I think that
was a pretty obvious one if you ask me
but and then we finished the game which
all right for us
nice beanie Jodi I like it alright so
that was beyond to sauce and it was a
lot of fun almost all the time I am I
don't know what say i love chronic
stream chronic games games i don't know
if my expectations have were met with
this one i don't think so i don't but i
don't i don't think that's their fault
it's just that i guess i wanted
something else out of this and then what
i got but i still really really really
liked it like i can't say that i didn't
enjoy it or anything but i i still
prefer hi brain it's still my my am my
champion because the thing that I
remember most out of a heavy rain is the
fact that I felt so part of the story I
felt like holy [ __ ] I have to find my
son I have to do all these things and if
I [ __ ] up we're not gonna do it and that
just made me feel like I'm part of the
story I'm I'm what at what I do is gonna
affect the story and I didn't feel like
that while playing this which is a shame
because I feel like the interactivity
with these games is what really makes
them so good you know feeling like
you're part of what's going on it's what
makes it so much better than a movie and
I feel like they tried too much here to
make it into a movie
it did add some positive effects to it
though with with all the beautiful
scenery and the framing I loved it
like seriously this this game was
incredibly beautiful probably one of the
most visually appealing games I am ever
played that that's that's how good it
was in that sense but in terms of what I
really want is its it would I don't know
it wasn't a bad story but it just wasn't
played out the way I would would have
preferred but I still I still like the
story a lot of the Orion and I don't
know why first I hated Ryan and then I
really kind of kind of dig him and then
hmm I don't know it's kind of hard to
wrap my head around I think next what I
would like to see is not a sequel please
don't make a sequel out of this game I
don't know why but I just I don't know
what they were hitting with the [ __ ]
thing in the last guy I don't know I
don't [ __ ] know but I hope they try
something else
I hope I hope David Craig Cage will do
something [ __ ] weird next time like
oh absolutely batshit crazy like do some
futuristic [ __ ] weird-ass thing that
I don't know I don't know anyway
I'll propose enjoyed watching it was a
lot of fun thank you for staying with me
goddamn I know I know I'm a I'm a [ __ ]
to watch too sometimes because I [ __ ]
suck at the action secrets I'm working
on it and I ruined some some teary
moments maybe but there was just so many
some times that I just felt like jeez
another one really like when I [ __ ] it
I'll just ramble too much thanks for
hanging around I'll see you in the next
one it comes to brough is you ready
you earned it you know what now you
didn't earn it but it would be pretty
sweet how about that all right here we
come South and rest
pick a youtube comment right